Now there was a very early time in my career where I learned a very valuable
lesson. I had just finished up an internship with a great game studio called
Petroglyph Games and I was actually on an on site interview for a new company.
I got into a light debate with someone during one of my interviews about what
things should be named. More specifically, we were describing what an object is
that walks around in the world. Unfortunately, I probably got too deep on that
conversation, and it turns out that I was actually arguing with the technical
director of the project over a naming convention. Needless to say, I didn't get
the job. The point was this, as game development goes on lots of people have
lots of different names for things. You just spend less time worrying about
what something called and more time worrying about what it does. Now pretty
much every game architecture out there is going to have some encompassing
object that has logic associated with it that may or may not have a visual
representation and may or may not actually be represented on the server. This
is a basic object that every game has. You can call it an actor or an entity or
a jabberwocky, for all it's concerned. Trust me. Worry less about the
nomenclature of what things are called, you'll get more jobs that way.